And the correct answer, if you remember this from the browser question,
is none of them.
Databases are very similar to browsers in that there are many of them,
and they all behave a little bit differently, and they all have their place
for solving different types of problems.
It's not uncommon for large websites to actually use multiple websites.
We'll be using the Google App Engine Datastore for most of our stuff,
but using Google App Engine doesn't limit you to this.
I think they also even provide some sort of MySQL interface,
if that's what you prefer to use.
The answer is there is no best database.
There is certainly the most popular database,
which is probably MySQL, of this list,
but there's definitely no best.